[Applaudissements]
mokhtar
vous avez vous avez préparé donc un
discours est là à ce qu'il faut merci il
a fait part des clubs qu'à vos gardes du
corps je me dis que vous êtes brésil à
vous êtes bien protégé un garde-corps
plus chétif mais qui protège je vous
remercie et vous pouvez arrêter
merci en tout cas merci monsieur le
maire vous êtes maire de touche pas à
mon poste merci mokhtar mokhtar vous
avez un discours à faire pour tous les
téléspectateurs de touche pas à mon
poste on vous écoute monsieur le maire
déjà je suis très heureux je suis très
heureux d'avoir été élu maire de touche
pas à mon poste je voudrais remercier
tous les gens qui ont voté pour moi et
c'était un très bon rétablissement aux
autres j'espère que je n'aurais pas fait
trop mal et bien on se retrouve bien sûr
en 2017 avec mon propre parti
votre pour moi où je défonce
[Rires]
merci à tous vive la république vive la
france et vive la sécu
[Applaudissements]